[Musik]
[Musik
] Nun, Kapitän, ich ging in den Raum, okay, meine
Mutter und mein Vater hielten eine der ersten
Versammlungen in ihrem Haus ab, und ich war damals ein
kleines Mädchen, und ich verteilte
damals Kekse in ihrem Haus, mein
Name ist  Linda Gayle, ich bin für das
bezahlte Filmmaterial des Bürgermeisters für den Präsidenten gewählt worden, und wir
sind an dem Punkt, an dem wir Energie und
eine jüngere Führungspersönlichkeit im Weißen Haus brauchen,
wir müssen ein Trauma sein und wir müssen heute Abend jemanden finden, den
ihr sehr machtvoll habt
von schrecklicher nacht eins oder aus welchem grund ich habe
in bisschen energie sorry ich jeman
wir sagen für einen kaffee naja
ir sind fast da [musi
] es ka
nur vorbei um sie zu fragen ob sie e
ne zweite wahl hätten wer ihre zweite wahl
könnte so sein, ich sagte, dass wir
es lieben würden, wenn sie sich der Ami-
Gruppe anschließen würden, wenn sie interessiert wären, also
das war's
[Musik]
35 Regionen
[Applaus]
[Musik]